well we've had reports that Marvel
Studios is getting rid of Kang after
they fired Jonathan Majors who of course
plays Kang the conquer in the MCU we got
reports that they are getting rid of the
character King altogether and even
Avengers King Dynasty is now simply
titled Avengers 5 at Marvel Studios and
today we have a brand new report that
states Marvel Studios actually plans to
keep King the Conqueror in the MCU
however he is not going to be a main
focus anymore at least not for a while
while now these reports may seem
conflicting but they actually aren't
they can go hand inand with each other
and I'll explain how now when Jonathan
Majors was fired by Marvel Studios
because he was found guilty in court
pretty much everyone was talking about
it all of the major Outlets like variety
deadline The Hollywood Reporter Forbes
talked about it the Rolling Stone talked
about it and everybody was talking about
the future of King the conquer in the
MCU and how it looks like Marvel is
going to move away from the character
but The Hollywood Reporter specific ific
Al reported that Avengers King Dynasty
was no longer titled King Dynasty but
simply titled Avengers 5 according to
their sources Insider Jeff Snyder said
the same thing he said I told you that
the next Avengers movie wouldn't be
called the King Dynasty the name King
only conjures thoughts of Jonathan major
and this part is most likely true the
next Avengers film which was supposed to
be king Dynasty will not be titled Kang
Dynasty but that doesn't mean Kang is
done in the MCU because according to
Alex Perez from the cosmic circus.com
Kang is going to be coming back and
Marvel Studios still does have plans for
Kang the Conqueror now of course
unfortunately I have to clarify this
Jonathan Majors will not be playing Kang
the Conqueror in the MCU they will
recast Kang Jonathan majors has been
fired from Marvel Studios he's not going
to come back and play King unless
perhaps he does an appeal and he wins
that appeal however that could take a
very very long time but according to
Alex Perez at the cosmic circus we won't
see king for a very long time even
though he's not done he's not going to
pop up until the very end so we do have
time and Majors could appeal in court
and possibly win I've seen a lot of
lawyers go on the news recently talking
about the case stating that he should
appeal and that he might actually have a
pretty decent chance at winning the
appeal so who knows what could happen
there but we're not going to count on it
besides in the meantime Marvel Studios
is probably going to want to jump on who
they want to replace him as king the
Conqueror in the MCU but let's break
down this new report talking about
King's future in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and if you're new and you want
to stay up to date on the MCU don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell we're also doing a
giveaway giving away a PS5 and Xbox
series X and more we'll talk about that
at the end so this new report again is
coming from Alex Perez at the cosmic
circus and he released this report in a
very very long and detailed article
about the future of the MCU I highly
suggest after you watch this video you
go and you check it out I'll link it
down in the description in the pin
comment and here's the thing from what
I've read from everything that you all
have commented on YouTube on Instagram
on Twitter it seems that most people
would prefer this option that is laid
out here in this article the section on
Kang is subtitled Kang currently on
standby it starts off by reading we
could not conclude this article without
addressing the elephant in the room King
the Conqueror following the guilty
verdict of the trial of Jonathan major
Marvel Studios quickly dismissed Majors
from his duties as king the Conqueror
and his variant we last Saw majors in
the MCU with the release of Loki season
2 in which he reprised his role as he
who remains and portrayed the variant
Victor timely by the show's end Loki had
taken control of the Multiverse and
created the multiversal tree which
allows infinite timelines to
continuously expand and grow as a giant
tree now the bigger question as the TVA
moves on is where does that leave Kang
and his variants many of which were all
gathered at limbo in a place outside of
time and space how does Marvel intend to
address Kang's absence Marvel's plan for
him is the equivalent of sweeping it
under the rug Marvel will instead focus
on other storylines while they take
their time to build up Kang and the
Multiverse again slowly behind the
scenes some sources have even gone
beyond that to state that Marvel doesn't
intend to address him directly until we
are practically near the end of the
Multiverse Saga sources state that there
have been discussions and plans for
other Multiverse ival villains to step
up to the plate in the upcoming phases
this is of course in an attempt to take
control of the multiversal sized vacuum
left in the absence of Kang the
Conqueror and his variant but make no
mistake For Better or Worse Marvel
ultimately still intends to close out
the Multiverse Saga with a Kang variant
as their final villain so according to
Alex Perez Marvel Studios still plans to
have at least one king the Conqueror
stick around in the m we won't see him
for a while but he'll pop up at the end
and they will still slowly build him up
now the reason fans might like this
option A lot is because Marvel Studios
has already built him up we've already
seen him three times in the MCU for if
you count the post credit for Ant-Man
and the was quantum Mania they've
already established that there is a
group of Kang variants out there the
Kang Trio the Council of kangs who have
gathered a mass Army we saw thousands
maybe hundreds of thousands of Kang
variants following three very specific
variants ramut am Morse and the Scarlet
Centurion and when news first broke out
that it looked like they were going to
replace Kang all together with a
different villain a lot of fans were
pretty disappointed because they've
already set them up in a pretty big way
and they want to see how that plays out
well the good news is it looks like we
will however not in the same fashion as
we would have before whereas before if
this never happened that Jonathan majors
and he never went to court and was found
guilty and he still was King the
Conqueror we would have seen him pop up
in a lot more places and of course of
course we would still have Avengers King
Dynasty now it doesn't look like we are
getting a Avengers King Dynasty film and
it doesn't really look like Kang is
going to pop up much for the rest of the
Multiverse Saga until the very end now
it seems like this still kind of lines
up with what Marvel studios's original
plans were for a final villain of Kang
and that was to be a beyonder Kang
variant which would make sense and would
kind of explain how you could kind of
just dismiss the other groups of Kang
that are out there in limbo outside of
space and time because the beyonder can
also exist outside of space and time but
they could add a cool little twist to
the beyonder variant of Kang you see
Kang the Conqueror his real name is
Nathaniel Richards he's just a human
I've said this before but he doesn't
have any actual Powers all of his powers
come from technology we saw this in
Quantum Mania Kang was stranded in the
quantum realm he had no powers he was
helpless until he got his suit back and
only then was he powerful and could now
build the giant city which we saw in the
quantum realm but if you add a king
beyonder variant then perhaps this
beyonder variant could have powers of
his own much like the actual beyonder
from Marvel Comics and this would pretty
much make all other variants of Kang
obsolete because this would be the
ultimate Kang variant one with powers
and technology so this could still work
and in the meantime they could bring in
other awesome villains I mean this was
pretty much how the infinity Saga was
the first aveng film wasn't entirely
about Thanos it was really about Loki
yes thanos's Army was behind it and Loki
was working for Thanos but the main
villain of that film was Loki the same
thing goes for Avengers Age of Ultron
Thanos wasn't behind Ultron Ultron was
his own separate villain he was the main
villain of that film then eventually
they had Thanos in Infinity war and
endgame yes he was kind of in the
background here and there but he wasn't
exactly a huge prominent person he was
never the main villain of a movie like
Kang was in quantam Mania before in
Infinity War so they could still make
this work they could still make it work
to where the big bad raid boss king the
Conqueror villain doesn't come in until
Avengers Secret Wars and he's the
villain that everybody has to take down
I also like this because this means that
Doom can be saved as a main villain for
a different Saga which is what I really
want Doom is a character that you really
have to spend a lot of time with to
truly understand and appreciate and I
think he deserves an entire Saga to
himself but let us know what you think
about these plans in the comments down
below about Marvel Studios plans to
essentially sweep Kang under the rug let
everything that happened with Jonathan
major die down don't say Kang for a
while because again that will kind of
bring up Jonathan Majors but then in the
end bring him back because they already
set him up for the story for Kang to be
the big bad multiversal villain so let
us know your thoughts and let us know
who you think should replace him as the
actor for King the Conqueror don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for chance to win a PS5 and
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
woof